Ich machte ursprünglich mal eine
Lehre als Detailhandelsangestellter.
Leider Gottes
arbeitete ich ein halbes Jahr lang
bei einem der grössten
Elektrofachmärkte in der Schweiz.
Ich empfand das als
die schlimmste Zeit meines Lebens.
Es waren sechs Monate,
in denen ich ...
... wirklich auch merkte ...
... wie vergiftet die Leute
konsumieren wollen,
was für einen krassen Stellenwert
das einnimmt
und wie die Leute sich vergessen,
wenn es darum geht:
"Kriege ich das?"
* Sanfte Musik *
Ja, ich würde mich
als Antikapitalisten bezeichnen.
Ich bin fest davon überzeugt,
dass das System,
so, wie wir es jetzt leben,
sich selber an die Wand fahren wird.
Ich bin Philippe und bin 33.
Ich wohne in Bern
in einer grossen WG
in einer gemeinsamen Ökonomie.
Ich gründete vor zwei Jahren
ein Start-up und bin Unternehmer.
Wir sind acht Erwachsene
und drei Kinder.
Es gibt Sozialarbeiterinnen
und einen Sexualpädagogen,
eine Gesangspädagogin,
eine Theologiestudentin,
einen Medienschaffenden,
einen Musikschaffenden -
also eine sehr bunte Truppe.
Grundsätzlich sind wir eine
Wohngemeinschaft und keine Kommune.
"Kommune" ist ein Wort,
das die Medien gerne benutzen.
Es wird mit viel assoziiert,
was hier nicht passiert.
Wir haben keine Orgien
und keine Gelage in diesem Sinne.
Wir wohnen aber gemeinschaftlich
und sehr nahe beieinander.
Wir teilen uns nicht nur das Haus
und die Haushaltsbeschaffungen,
sondern auch unser Geld.
Die gemeinsame Ökonomie bedeutet,
dass wir unsere Einkommen
zusammen auf einem Konto verwalten.
Von diesem Konto
bezahlen wir all unsere Ausgaben.
Wir bestreiten unser Leben
mit dem Geld,
das uns zur Verfügung steht.
Wir haben eine Karte.
Diese benutzen wir ganz normal -
wie unsere Bank-
oder Postkontokarte.
Es gibt überhaupt keine Regelungen
oder Bestimmungen.
Jeder kann walten und schalten,
wie er möchte.
* Sanfte Musik *
Als ich das zum ersten Mal hörte,
dachte ich: "Seid ihr wahnsinnig?"
Also ich glaube,
meine erste Reaktion auf ...
... die gemeinsame Ökonomie
war gleich wie diejenige
meiner Freunde und Familie.
Ich war sehr erstaunt,
dass es - erstens -
überhaupt ein solches Konzept gibt.
Und zweitens:
viel Unverständnis
für die Idee an sich.
Es ist ja eigentlich nichts anderes
als eine grosse Familie.
Ich glaube, es sind Strukturen, die
früher viel mehr so gelebt wurden
und sich erst
in den letzten 40, 50 Jahren
so etabliert haben.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ja, vielleicht ist unser Garten
wie ein Spiegel von dem,
wie wir gerne leben.
Wir lassen es gerne leben -
wie man sieht.
Das ist während der Sommermonate
ein guter Zustupf
für unsere Haushaltskasse.
Wir haben eben
einen ziemlich grossen Garten,
aber nicht so, dass man
längerfristig davon leben könnte.
Mmh!
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir leben in einer Gesellschaft,
in welcher der Mensch dazu tendiert,
sein Glück
über den Konsum zu befriedigen.
Das ist eine Vorstellung, die ich
sehr gut nachvollziehen kann.
Ich funktionierte selber auch so
und tue es immer noch:
"Konsumieren macht glücklich."
Aber es ist einfach sehr kurzlebig.
Es ist so ...
... ein Glück,
das einem für den Moment etwas gibt.
Schlussendlich
ist es aber nicht das Glück,
das du im Leben suchst.
Das ist nicht das, was du bekommst,
wenn du dich geborgen
und als Teil von etwas fühlst.
So!
Wie spät ist es?
Die Zeit vergeht nämlich schnell.
* Sanfte Musik *
Also, gehen wir ... ähm ...
Rafi hat ja das Finanzamt.
Ähm ...
Ich habe heute kurz nachgesehen,
wie es mit dem Kontostand aussieht.
Nicht so schlecht.
Es ist ... äh ...
Also es sind 6'500 Fr. oder so
auf dem Konto.
Dein Lohn
ist noch nicht auf dem Konto.
Ja,
wir haben gerade unsere Haussitzung,
unser Plenum, das wir
alle zwei bis drei Wochen abhalten -
je nachdem,
wie die Leute da sind oder nicht.
Da geht es eben auch darum,
dass wir abschätzen können:
Reicht es? Oder müssen wir
noch Geld vom Ersparten nehmen?
"Bei mir steht das an.
Ich würde gerne das kaufen."
Oder: "Das wird kommen."
Wir haben eine Zahl gesucht, die
irgendwie in einem Mittelmass ist,
so, dass man ...
... unabhängig und individuell
trotzdem Sachen kaufen kann,
auf die man Lust hat,
ohne dass man es anmelden muss.
Wir haben uns auf 400 Fr. geeinigt.
400 Fr. ist der Betrag,
bei dem man sein Bedürfnis
anmelden kann oder sollte.
Ich glaube,
wichtig ist noch zu erwähnen,
dass wir Bedürfnisse
nicht verhandeln,
sondern man überlegt, wie man
das Bedürfnis befriedigen kann.
Noch eine Frage zu den GAs:
Wann kommt das genau?
Meines ist bis Ende Oktober gültig.
Meines ist erst im November
oder Dezember fällig.
Ich würde sagen,
wir lassen es einfach mal laufen.
Ja.
Und wir reagieren, wenn wir sehen,
dass wir wirklich eine Lücke haben.
Wir wenden ... äh ...
... alle zwei oder drei Wochen
15 oder 30 Minuten auf,
um die gemeinsame Ökonomie ...
... ähm ... zu verwalten.
Gleichzeitig haben wir aber eine
enorme Unabhängigkeit und Freiheit.
Wir haben z.B. ein Rechnungsamt.
Ich lege meine Rechnungen in ein
Fach und dann werden diese bezahlt.
Dann kann man das sparen.
Also ich bin überzeugt:
Ich gewinne mehr,
als dass ich investiere.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich brauche zwischen
2'000 und 3'000 Fr. im Monat.
Mit 2'000, 3'000 Fr. im Monat ...
... gehe ich eigentlich
ziemlich angenehm und ...
... ohne Verzicht durchs Leben.
Jetzt bin ich auf dem Weg ...
... nach Urtenen-Schönbühl,
zu unserem
neuen Genossenschaftsprojekt,
an dem wir
seit fast eineinhalb Jahren sind.
Ich unterstütze
den Baustellensupport
und helfe beim Kochen.
* Popmusik *
Ja, es ist eine wahre Freude,
hier reinzukommen.
So cool!
Es ist mir sehr wichtig -
im Sinne von:
Wir gehen einen Schritt weiter.
Wir vergrössern uns.
Wir wachsen.
Wir können neue Leute
für unsere Idee gewinnen.
Für mich persönlich
ist es auch ein Traum,
ein eigenes Haus zu bauen.
Zusammen hat man halt einfach
einen grösseren, finanziellen Hebel
und mehr Möglichkeiten,
ein solches Projekt zu realisieren,
als wenn man z.B.
in einer Kernfamilie
ein solches Projekt angehen würde.
Dort unten sind Kekse.
Muss man noch
den Käse bereit machen?
Soll ich ein Pack rausstellen?
- Ja!
Das Essen ist das Wichtigste,
damit der Bau gut läuft.
Darum geben wir uns immer Mühe,
dass es etwas Köstliches
zu essen gibt.
Von der Organisation her ist es so,
dass wir uns gegen eine
grosse Baufirma entschieden haben,
gegen eine Generalunternehmung,
und lieber in kleineren Unternehmen,
die auch genossenschaftlich
organisiert sind, arbeiten.
Hey, wer hat gekocht? Chrigel?
Geile Suppe!
Mmh!
Wir finanzieren dieses Projekt
einerseits aus Eigenmitteln
und andererseits aus Darlehen
und Genossenschaftsanteilen,
die wir von ganz vielen,
grosszügigen Menschen
bekommen haben.
Ich persönlich hätte nie gedacht,
dass wir das ...
... finanziell stemmen können -
alleine schon nur,
wenn du diese Zahlen hörst.
Es sind riesige Zahlen!
Aber das Schöne ist, dass man sich
dann auch gegenseitig in der Gruppe
abholen und einander beruhigen kann.
Ja, das ist eine weitere Stärke
der Gemeinschaft.
Also Frühstück eine Stunde
und am Mittag zwei Stunden gekocht.
Nachher habe ich oben ...
- Hast du geputzt, oder was?
Genau, ich habe oben geputzt.
- Okay.
Das war am 22.
- Einfach gekocht?
Ja.
- Wie lange?
Drei Stunden.
- Mit Mittag?
Ja.
Ich habe mit ihm noch kurz
meine Einsätze besprochen
von den Baustellenrapporten,
die wir ausfüllen.
Wir füllen sie aus dem Grund aus,
weil unsere Bank ...
... Arbeitszeit
als Eigenkapital anrechnet
und wir das denen belegen
und dokumentieren müssen.
Ohne unsere Eigenleistung,
ohne diese Möglichkeit,
wäre dieses Projekt
nicht finanzierbar gewesen.
Ich denke, jeder in der Gemeinschaft
versucht auch,
nach seinem Einkommen
sein Leben zu bestreiten.
Natürlich haben wir sehr stark
die solidarische Komponente,
was ich mega wichtig finde.
Im Sinne von:
Man kann auch mal einen Monat lang
keinen Lohn bringen.
Man kann sich eine Auszeit nehmen
oder in meinem Fall
ein Unternehmen gründen.
Man kann sich halt nicht jeden Monat
einen Lohn auszahlen.
Das ist nur möglich,
weil ich in dieser Gemeinschaft
auch so aufgefangen werde.
* Popmusik *
Und jetzt
sind wir in der Herba di Berna.
Das ist unser Start-up, das wir
vor zwei Jahren gegründet haben.
Hier kultivieren wir CBD-Hanf.
Es ist nicht  m e i n  Geschäft.
Die Herba di Berna
ist eine Aktiengesellschaft
und die Hauptaktionärin der Herba
ist unsere gemeinsame Ökonomie.
Dementsprechend kommt auch das,
was ich hier erwirtschafte,
also das,
was ich als Lohn bekomme ...
... wieder zurück
in die gemeinsame Ökonomie.
Geld ist ein nötiges Übel.
Ich glaube,
das ist meine Beziehung zum Geld.
Geld ermöglicht einem vieles.
Darum brauchen wir auch Geld.
Darum müssen wir dieses Unternehmen
auch so führen,
dass es auf irgendeine Art und Weise
der Wirtschaftlichkeitsprämisse
untersteht.
Wir können das nicht
wegphilosophieren,
das bringt nichts.
Wir unterliegen dem Markt genauso
wie unsere Konkurrenz
und unsere Marktteilnehmer.
Ich versuche einfach,
mein Leben so zu leben,
dass ich mir
die Herzenswünsche erfüllen kann,
die für mich wirklich wichtig sind.
Dafür setze ich meine Energie ein.
Ich wende in dem Sinn
weniger Energie
für irgendwelche Konsumartikel
und Güter auf,
die man sich ja auch verdienen muss
und für die man auch arbeiten muss.
Es ist eine anstrengende Zeit.
Wenn man ein Unternehmen führt,
ein Haus baut,
sich politisch engagiert
und die Welt verändern will,
hat man einfach keine Zeit,
um nichts zu tun.
Das ist doch mal ein Schlusswort,
was?
Ist es gerade?
Nein, es ist nicht gerade, oder?
So gut!
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ich glaube,
ich sehe dieser ganzen Sache
mit dem Alter ...
Ja, ich habe
eine andere Perspektive dazu.
Was wir jetzt hier gerade aufbauen,
soll weitergedacht
auch ein Stück weit
eine Altersvorsorge sein.
Diese Vorstellung
finde ich total schön:
einen Ort zu haben,
wo man hinkommen kann,
mehrere Generationen zusammenleben
und dieses solidarische
Zusammenwohnen auch gelebt wird.